well you know me I'm Sean mine a
visiting subs Institute for the for the
spring and so the I asked to sort of
give a crash course in stochastic
approximation in part because I say here
there's a hidden theory and so a lot of
experts in stochastic approximation
would laugh at me and they say that's
not hidden it's in every book but if you
look at the books and suggest
approximation they're intimidating and
and many people don't read them and in
particular I think when I talk to people
in the reinforcement learning community
it's clear that many of them have not
read those books and so so there's a lot
of really cool ideas that are hidden in
the stochastic approximation literature
which are not being used in any way and
I'll show you I'll explain why um so
this is joint work but it's actually
started with my very first sabbatical in
India a million years ago with Yvette
Borkar and more recently this is with my
graduate student Aditya who's right
there and what I'm talking about
basically I'm sorry I'm sort of
reviewing my favorite chapters of the
beg for cars book and this is a
photograph of him showing that he's kept
his berkeley roots so he said this to me
last night
business he of I guess giving it before
giving a talk on bandits somewhere and
there's a tease here and so there's this
book which you can actually download a
few clever it actually is as a PDF file
around and it's an excellent book and
there's a tutorial that we wrote a tiny
part of it is for the nips conference
whilst last year but you can download
this I think I in the abstract on the
website you can find it downloads link
okay so you can find lots of references
in these slides which are available and
in these in this spoken-tutorial and I
should warn you so I made the slides
available available in advance and over
the last 24 hours I found lots of typos
and so you might want to refresh later
on so I'll make the new slides available
okay so here is like a very detailed
table of contents for part one and and
it's mainly for somebody who's like
knows nothing about this
and so you can run out now if that's not
you but I'm basically in in the first
part I'm just going to remind you or
tell you what stochastic approximation
is and what it's supposed to solve and
the most clear example is Monte Carlo I
have I want to find the mean of a
function of a random variable
but reinforcement learning is a big
application area and it what's called
empirical risk minimization and I wanted
to spell what I think are some myths
about that area and maybe I want to be
if I'm wrong tell me I'm really confused
myself about what erm is it's 1/3 of
nips was devoted to that subject and I'm
a little confused
and then I'm going to talk about this od
methods which is like the motivation for
stochastic approximation and the mode of
analysis and it's hidden Theory there as
well in particular this is stochastic
differential equation approximations as
well as OD ease and that's the biggest
thing that is hidden that really needs
to be understood better it's very simple
and for some reason it's not even talked
it's the last chapter of vivec workhorse
book it's just ignore it even though I
think it's incredibly important part of
this period and so at the close I'll
talk about how you optimize the variants
in these algorithms and once you
understand that the the next step part 2
will be clear you know really how are we
going to apply these ideas to the
enforcement learning and the impact is
pretty amazing how much you can improve
these algorithms so cute learning any
way you talk to they'll say q Lorraine's
ridiculously slow you'll learn why today
and next lecture okay so stochastic
proximation that's the goal we have some
random function of parameter theta and
we want to take the expectation and find
the theta star which that expectation is
zero alright that's that's the
definition of the goal is to gastric
approximation and so I will give several
examples of why this is this comes up
what you care
all right so first of all why this is so
naive to most of you it's almost hard
for me to say it you know we all know
why this is a hard thing to do is that
first of all of course you might not
know anything you might not know the
random variable W you might not know
that your function out we might not only
know something about the structure of
the problem that is what's claimed in
reinforcement learning you the claim is
I can go to Wall Street in to stare
stock prices and my black box will learn
an algorithm that will come up with
optimal decision rules for investments I
think that might be a myth I don't think
that blackbox learning for control is
real
my personal belief you know and I'll
keep an open mind I think I think in
reality we're gonna build models that
simulate reality you know well-well take
reality and then build simulators but
the way we enforce millenia is sold is
that you just stare at Wall Street and
algorithm pops out just from
input-output data there's simulation
based L are there they're based on data
we write with it small it was random in
that case you don't know every W
anything you just absolutely model free
but that I think again I think that's
less realistic most the time we come up
with some sort of model but even in that
case of course this might be high
dimensional and we don't want to compute
this expectation over and over and over
again for the purposes of route-finding
you know if we were gonna try to use
this to Santa Newton Rapson or whatever
I mean that's our even some zero finding
algorithm we wouldn't want to have to
integrate over and over again to find
finding expectation that's what I mean
about being so naive it's not worth
repeating almost but a few of you might
want to hear that the thing is so we
come with the curse of algorithms and
based on getting rid of that expectation
that's what stochastic approximation is
what would you find as I said is that
they're incredibly slow so Kela I need
is dismissed it's so absurdly slow
people often just say forget it and
again I mean in this lecture that for
discount factor is bigger than 1/2
the variance is infinity Viki learning
it and once you understand that you can
fix it all right and you can optimize it
so that's that's that's what I'd like to
explain these in the 90 minutes today
I'd like to make big make it all clear
okay so they won so that was why now is
what so the original 1950s algorithm of
Robinson Munroe is to basically just get
rid of the expectation sign and come
with a sequence of estimates of that
zero and and so forth and and there it
is now the step size there that game
it's it zooms you see it sums to
infinity it's non-negative so I'm sure
infinity the reason for that is you want
to be able to get anywhere you know so
you bought it you if this was fine all
right
there'd be a finite distance you could
travel and so that's the reason for that
and the reason you have this if square
summable will be obviously there on but
it's to attenuate noise so they're two
two conditions so well these these you
know two hours at sea hours I'll take
this to be one of our and I'll have this
one exception but usually just one of
around and there's good reasons for that
which I will explain okay so so if you
write it this way if you basically so
that f bar means the mean that we had
before and then this thing here that is
zero man so this whole thing is if the
definition of that well this is a zero
main sequence then you can see if that's
just an oil approximation and didn't
have the noise of an Eau de and oil
approximations should be robust under
under reasonable conditions and so this
noise here shouldn't bother you if
you're trying to approximate another EE
we hope that our OD approximations are
robust enough to handle a little bit of
noise and that's that's a theory of
stochastic approximation in a nutshell
is that we're approximating that easy
now
I'll make that precise
so we got that ready like that just a
definition of a delta is a zero-mean
sequence and that hopefully approximates
that and it does under very very general
conditions and the graduate students out
there you are so lucky because when I
was a graduate student this was so
opaque and scary and intimidating and
now the theory is so crisp and beautiful
and clear you can explain it all in in
45 minutes all right
so examples so the first example is just
I have a function of a random variable I
want to compute the mean you know call
it a de I've got some density say that I
know maybe but maybe this density is in
r12 and so I don't want to you know
perform this integration of r12 I'm lazy
it's just it's annoying so this is an
examples of stochastic approximation
because we have a function of a random
variable and theta namely C of X minus
theta and want the mean of that to be
zero want to find the value of theta for
which the mean of that is zero all right
but forget the general theory you all
know what you would do you would just
take the sample path average where the x
i's could be iid or generated from a
Markov chain or whatever but these guys
all have the same distribution you
average them out and you're right that's
the best way to go all right that'll end
up under and do very gentle conditions
on the stochastic process X all right
this will be a optimal on some sense
estimator than mean so what's the
connection so if you unravel this
average so basically I'm going to do any
thing if you take theta and x and you
just could have some okay so n plus 1
times theta n plus 1 is a sum it's just
a sum of the N plus 1 observations if
you like C of X I and that sum of n plus
1 elements is just n times theta n
because it's also a sum plus the new
term right and then I can add 1 and
subtract ones I've got a minus 1 there
and a plus 1 there
see that's an N and that's an N plus one
and he's starting to see that looks
familiar that's like the difference you
see up there and now I can divide both
sides by n plus one and I'll get a 1
over n plus 1 there which is a gain and
that's my elf and it appears there all
right so so basically standard
Montecarlo is a special case of
stochastic approximation and it's the
best choice so you could stick in
anything there that satisfies these two
conditions and for some choices you'd
see complete chaos comes out it would
converge but it would look like a mess
pop potentially depending on how you how
you how you define your your you would
say well fan so in this particular case
remember the choice one of our n is
optimal in certain sense it's in the
proof of optimality is like this proof
of optimality you can boil it down to a
common filter problem it's like you have
a state process which is constant what
you're trying to estimate you derive the
common filter you'll basically get
Montecarlo the only difference is
instead of one of our n we get 1 over n
plus a constant basically it's you can
there's a lot of ways to prove that this
has an optimal variance estimator
all right great you all still awake I
promise this would be fun I'm not sure
if I've proven that yet okay so what
about stochastic what about
reinforcement learning so if you take a
course in stochastic control you'll see
dynamic programming equations come up
over and over and over again for optimal
stopping average cost optimal control
discounted optimal control you know half
finding problems all sorts of things in
every single one of them there's a
function 8star that you want to find
it's a value function of something else
and there's some crazy functional of
that function and a stochastic process
and this this capital F takes functions
to functions you know and this
conditional expectation given past
random variables should be 0 all right
and that's mr. Casten control is you
derive equations like that but you could
never solve and they thien's going to be
one state or many states of a Markov
decision process a controlled Markov
chain and also inputs or actions
I'll give it I'll make that explicit
next time now there's something called a
choleric and relaxation where you get
rid of the conditional expectation
instead you multiply by a vector-valued
process which is adapted to this so Zeta
and there is a some function of these of
these observations and and instead of
searching over all functions you've
searched over parameters family there's
a part of the design of an algorithm is
to find this parameterize family or if
they to say an RD so you know finite
dimensional space and there's this Zeta
n which is called a test function in
this world it's also d dimensional so
because of this is a D dimensional
vector equation you've got D constraints
and D unknowns that's the rationale this
capital F is takes out real values it's
a you know I mean it takes functions to
functions right it's a random here Bobby
said it it takes the it takes a function
with stochastic process to another real
valued random variable that's a I think
I'll get I'll make that code later on
but is it all clear so this is a scalar
random variable I multiplied by D
dimensional random vector and so if I
set that equal to zero I have D unknowns
D constraints
so that is what you know we look at all
the time because if you look at TD
learning or Q learning that's not how
they were proposed in the literature but
after the fact it's been understood that
all it was always glare can relaxations
in every single case TD learning is
always a clerical equations there are
special cases where they're solving a
minimum norm problem but that's it
that's a very very special case it's not
user of them and so and in that special
context these test functions are called
eligibility vectors that's a term you'll
see over and over again so the TD
learning and Q learning are special
cases of stochastic approximation and
I'm saying this on tape some people in
this field say no it's not true some
experts in this field so it's absolutely
false that Q learning is can be housed
you know couched in suggested
approximation it's just that's not true
I think I simply think that in CST
approximation you have to have certain
martingales or ID or something there's a
misunderstanding the literature and
there's a big swath of people in the
reinforcement learning community will
stand by the claim that this is false
you know but there's a proof you know
this is absolute proof all right and so
we're gonna get I had explained what I
mean by this you know give I'll give the
equations for Q linear next lecture
okay empirical risk minimization so here
the goal is optimization I've got a
function G say let's call J J of theta
an expectation of G of theta W W again
just like before it's somewhere in a
variable which I don't know and we can
again we can't minimize that because we
don't want to do integration so instead
we settle this empirical risk and we and
we know there's been miraculous
algorithms to just try to solve this to
find the minimizer of this quickly for
high dimensional problems and that's
awesome so if you're in a very high
dimensional setting like these million
variables people talk about which blows
my mind
you need specialized algorithms to solve
this but if you're not in a high
dimensional setting I don't know what
the fuss is I don't get it at all
because of this don't forget that we
really wanted to solve that we settled
for this and there's an error between
what you wanted which was to minimize
this and what you actually minimized and
under very gentle conditions that you
can show is the error it's gonna be
approximately Gaussian Gaussian
distribution with some covariance which
we can compute today you know and
stochastic approximation could do the
same thing so if you design stochastic
approximation right you will have
exactly the same error and maybe maybe
faster because you don't have to store
all the data it's a lot of the
algorithms the empirical risk
minimization you have to store
everything and and and sift through it
over and over and over again for
moderate dimensional problems that could
be crazy so is I think I think see
people have forgotten what the problem
is they were trying to solve sometimes
at least that's the impression I've
gotten from soon I'm going to some talks
to the last year and I also heard
somebody once say basically stochastic
approximation is obsolete because
empirical risk minimization is so fast
now that statement doesn't make sense
because solving that fast exactly is a
noble cause but we but you always face
with this error between what you want
what you and salt and getting
approximation to theta star is it
stochastic proximation is awesome it's a
nice with cursive algorithm you don't
have to store anything so a lot of times
it's the way to go
so let's not lose track about
any questions those are those examples
let's the examples are the most
interesting and I'd love to get some
feedback on that because I'm just I'm
still learning I mean the motivation and
very high dimensions it's so I mean I
can definitely see you need some very
special tools to try to minimize alright
alright so let's get to the analysis
alright so and I tried to make this like
just give you the main feel of the
theory without getting to every epsilon
and Delta and I think you can do that so
here's the starting point of all
analysis you do this wonderful trick of
creating a time scale for analysis so
basically alpha and was our gain and
that algorithm which it's 1 over N and
the TN is just summing up the L fans so
if alpha is 1 over n TN is like a log n
we're just sending one over and we
construct a continuous time process
which I'll call XT and XT is just theta
n if T equals TN and otherwise it's just
piecewise linear it's continuous in
piecewise linear and and then we go
through and we look at this the
definition of the stochastic
approximation recursion if you iterate
is just that what I've done here is I've
just that is just alpha J but I'm
writing delta T to make it look like a
DT okay that's just alpha J and this is
just the thing I've always been looking
at thank you no because this is just
theta K and that's just a to n alright
I'm just using different letters for
what I had before and iterating so
clearly that looks like an integral plus
some error term alright so this is where
you make precise effect that stochastic
approximation is an Euler scheme with
noise and this noise here there's an
error here in part because we're
approximating integral by a sum that's
pretty easy to deal with and there's
also an issue because of the fact that
there's noise here which is you know
persistent yeah we'll be multiplying by
something small and that's what allows
us to it gets averaged out and
disappears I'll make that precise okay
all right so properties of this I'll
call this ignore is the properties
follow from F and W okay all right so
finally there's a trick here is to take
a really long fixed time window T and
take some capital T ends such the
increments converge to capital T this is
a subsequence of the little T ends and
so basically get to all of our analysis
on finite windows from TN to TN plus one
and everything comes down to this
basically looking at robustness of ot
ease on a finite time window that's all
all boils down to and then you once you
understand how to understand your noise
the rest of its a deterministic analysis
which is quite simple so let me write
down what it looks like
so again alpha K equals K at 1 over K
what you get is that the noise is looks
exactly like this is what I call Delta K
plus 1 does zero mean term so it's it's
the f bar which is the expectation of
the conditional expectation of that plus
a term which is like Big O of M 2 minus
2 he was so many summing from am and if
W would say Markovian most people stick
to ie D right away to forget that
Markovian is the most common situation
for applications F is Lipschitz and
theta we're always going to assume that
just like we do fro DS generally and
nice and W that's why I'd have to give a
whole course in Markov chains so I can't
explain what I mean by nice and W I can
only give you references well what you
end up with is something that this noise
chairman is a Mart is a difference of
martingales and really nice martingale
it's its second moment is uniformly
bounded in time and plus in junk which
is completely trivial it's like things
that you would have seen if you're doing
an oil approximation this just little
simple junk terms
which could a zero quickly and you can
just ignore and the mystery is this
martingale where does it come from and
unfortunately people write books often
they just assume this and the start and
never explain where they got it from and
I wish I had time to explain where you
get this I but only for those of you who
want to see in the future so but for the
experts the way you the way you get this
martingale is a friend of mine called
force owns equation which I won't define
but it's the way that you get a
martingale from a zero-mean sequence for
Markov chains
you give me almost any zero main
function of a Markov process I will give
you a plus on equation and then a
martingale that goes along with it
that's all I'm gonna say so you have to
know something about Markov chains to be
able to do this and and it doesn't you
know that's it this this is like a
telescoping sequence that's a simple
term that disappears it's just junk and
that's that that the telescoping series
which involves something called Hassan's
equation so kind of not defining is how
you get this nice martingale it makes it
makes the whole machine work so the the
technical part in stochastic
approximation is about Markov chains and
martingales things like that once you
get that under the rug the rest of it is
just like deterministic OD analysis it's
like there's nothing left so here's a
menu of Odie's for you all right so
first one is another bit of hidden
theory so one of the things that's sort
of a block right away when you look at
stochastic approximation is assumption
one is always that the sequence of
estimates theta and is bounded and how
are you gonna verify that it used to be
there was only one way you had to
construct a layup and a function for
that stochastic process and and get some
supermartingale results and get bound in
this so it's very problem specific and
sometimes that took a lot of ingenuity
to make it work so this there's a it
turns out that if you take
well what we call it the OD infinity so
take that f bar that we're trying to
minimize so f bar f theta is a thing
we're trying to minimize put in any X
you want scale it by a constant R
divided by r and let our go to infinity
you're going to get a function which is
homogeneous in the sense that you know F
of 2x is going to be 2 f of X so it's a
simpler function of X and it turns out
if that OD is stable then the stochastic
model is stable as well it's a really
useful fact to know okay because this is
often just strips away everything it
also it make this often this so de is
just way simpler than the one you
started with and all the lot of the
complexity disappears and it's really
nice to have a deterministic thing to
look at and if that's stable the
stochastic process is stable in the
sense of the iterates around it so I'm
I'm not going to prove that it's just
something to keep in your memory bank I
am going to prove this the convergence
result I'm going to give you the ideas
and once you understand the convergence
result then this is identical proof here
is identical so the convergence is that
basically we can week we have this this
o de and remember I said we're going to
do analysis on on six time a windows of
lengths approx capital T so what we're
going to do is we're going to
reinitialize the OTE at the what at the
at the at the parameter estimate theta K
you know theta theta of course finding
2x DK and we're gonna keep we initialize
new so de and look at a time window and
compare and compare and compare and
compare as K gets larger and larger and
something magical happens
all right and I'll need a picture in a
moment off to show that again but we
have a node either which we keep
reinitializing that's that's the genius
and i should say some history here i
mean a lot of people give Hirsch and Ben
a game credit for really crystallizing
things and making it clear and I'll
accept that I think so I guess that it's
the best the best history but but this
all came about from a lot of
collaboration it's a very diffuse field
ok so anyway so that's something I'll
explain in detail in a moment so this is
just a rough thing there's also a
stochastic differential equation
approximation which I'll talk about
I bet could prove anything but something
amazing happens is that you linearize
the model you end up with an a matrix
which will explain and a damned 1/2 eye
which will explain as well which really
messes things up in terms of intuition
and that's some hidden theory that I
need to explain and that's what messes
up q-learning that 1/2 I so big you know
my remaining 40 minutes whatever the big
thing is explain why that comes about
and why it's it's it should be taken
seriously all right so anyway so there's
a menu hodes really important you know
an SD into Odie's I'm going to explain
that in detail and then give some
examples ok so again in one word the
Euler's scheme for solving and OD is
robust under conditions and what are the
conditions so first of all we want
global asymptotic stability of the so de
so from an initial condition you can
verge to theta star and global
asymptotic stability is stronger than
that it means if you start in your theta
star you stay in your theta star forever
and that's really important we're gonna
use that Delta Epsilon as I'm not going
to use but you know all right and so we
need Lipschitz continuity we need that
for existence of solutions to
differential equations but it's
especially important here that global
Lipschitz continuity to get this theory
to work
then we need nice noise and that's
what's nice that's what you get for nice
Markov models you know like finite state
sees Markov chains
problem we're gonna get that this noise
term because it is zero uniformly on
these intervals of length T that were
considering and again the sequence is
bounded we're going to get that to the
so D infinity or some other technique
those are the assumptions the first two
are purely deterministic and then you
need to deal with the noise alright so
then we're done I mean we've done
I mean it's take a look at this we've
got our process here which I said is
just written this way by definition of
the other one by root n yeah yeah so
yeah I can write here can't I
so so so we are gonna show ah
the theory is so clean now you know
except almost sure convergence to theta
star the zero under these conditions I
mean it's done you'll see it's very very
quick the other result is look at the
square root of n times theta tilde then
so whenever you see me writes Hilda's
I'm going to be writing something - it's
it's limit that's going to converge for
Gaussian random variable distribution
I know much stronger conditions
which I'll explain by the time we're
done okay and some particularly
q-learning
doesn't hold it doesn't hold you got it
you got it
play around with the algorithm a bit and
you can make this whole it turns out
this goes just 4 goes to 0 slower than 1
of a square root of n under very general
conditions
that's for Nelson s oh it's in your
suite no it's just having everything
compact it's beautiful for analysis
that's all you'll see yeah you'll see
it's just a it's a it's a nice trick for
analysis you know make things really
precise I'd have to say for all epsilon
I'm gonna find a delta blah blah blah
I'm just gonna do this much more
poetically you know ok so we have this
error this error term here which we know
goes to 0 uniformly on compact sets you
know that's the I don't I'm sorry oh not
that error yeah this error term I don't
use it this gives is their uniform of
compact sets and therefore its supreme
goes to 0 as n goes to infinity because
that goes to 0 this is a thing we'd like
to bound and say something about let's
play with this so basically just take
differences between this and this that
and that are the same because this
differential equation was initialized
with because if you take differences and
use the fact that this functions
Lipschitz so I can just take the
difference well let's get L times the
error and then I'm going to take this a
superset and I'll just skip that this is
just taking the difference here and
playing around I get that that clear
it's nothing to it I'm just using the
Lipschitz continuity all right
and then you've got Grunwald lemma or
bellman gronwall slow-mo depending which
camp you live in and from that bound you
get that bound and and there's the
answer to your questions so that
difference is converging to capital T as
n goes to infinity L is fixed that goes
to sit with n so we have a uniform bound
because the 0 so this error term goes to
0 you
formerly in NT is n goes to infinity on
this compact interval which is all we
care about and explain that why that's
all we care about I have to give you
four little implications so at first
sight that doesn't look like very much
because we keep reinitializing this eau
de weave monkeyed around with it you
know maybe maybe this initialization is
this way off some faraway point and we
just because we just have this chaotic
behavior all right it turns out that
this immediately just implies everything
you want exactly this era goes to zero
uniform a and T and his ingress infinite
uniformly and T on the bounded interval
okay so here it is a picture yeah yes
analysis tool because at the end you
know if I was doing this you know in any
of these books I'd say give me an
epsilon I'm gonna prove that the Lim
soup of of this error is less than
epsilon and I'll have to get a bunch of
deltas in there and use global
asymptotic stability in a very careful
way you know and so that the T is so big
well it's right here what the
significance right there what I saying
so I'm gonna choose the T so large it's
in here somewhere I think
right yeah yeah so I say like so I knew
choose it so remember theta n is bounded
and I'm really realized he lead OD e
with some parameter I've seen so all the
initializations that Eau de are in some
compacts had some ball I'm gonna choose
capital T so large that no matter where
I started in that ball I'm going to end
up in some little neighborhood of theta
star so you know this is a this is the
parameter axis think of that as Rd and I
could put up a little ball around that
no matter where I start I'm gonna end up
in that little ball for the Eau de and
I'll make that precise here so separate
so if I global asymptotic stability at
the end of the run there's a minus there
at the end of the the n plus one and
thrown so X ends you know is initialized
at TN I'm looking just at the end of the
run it's in this tiny Delta ball or
epsilon ball of theta star so it started
off far away but you can shot in it
start off far away but it's shot in know
better every single time you get x zero
at the end the Eau de ended up right
next to the theta star by the end of its
run all right so there's a delta in
there the difference in between them as
delta now this guy you know these two
are equal by definition the n plus one
so de is initialized at the interpolated
process but this guy's a beautiful
Lipschitz continuous process and you
know it's going to be close to where it
was a a microsecond ago you know it's
continuous and and we know that you know
we know that these guys are close we've
said this that little minus sign doesn't
bother the X T at all if you'd like put
a minus there these the mines are the
same but isn't continuous so it doesn't
need a - alright so that means that I've
initialized my n plus one guy really
close to theta star saying some delta
ball and then he used global asymptotic
stability
that if I've started in some Delta ball
around theta star I will say an epsilon
ball around theta star and that's what
that is so if this is true then the Eau
de is always going to be near theta star
for large N and all T you know all T in
the interval of interest and it's not it
we already said these guys are close
together the OD and the stochastic
crosses are close together and we said
that's close to beta star that's the
definition of convergence all right so
so that's that's just you know wonderful
how clean it is how just once you get
that you know that once you get that
taken care of which you can get out of
you know a textbook the rest of it is
just Elementary analysis of Odie's
there's no you're starting here the
Odie's history analysis is just analysis
so XT capital X T you know is the
interpolated or process and this cute
cute trick of reinitializing the Eau de
and put everything a compact interval
it's just so clean as it's fantastic
so yeah so the and I think I think bars
book is the best place for catching this
if you
all right cool so that this was like the
big heavy technical bit you know they
said it's not much more that's uh it's
difficult but you can say four steps and
uh alright alright so now st
approximations here's where i found a
mistake in my slaw it's a dual easily my
car that caught me here it is I'm not
gonna get into this there's a functional
central limit theorem
look at Chris Union and it's the only
way to deal with like Markovian always
cleanly is to do exactly the same thing
as before but there's that that plus
thought equation I mentioned before and
all that it gives you conditions under
which if I take that noise and multiply
by the square root of t I get a Brownian
motion approximation and I can compute
the covariance and all that and then you
linearize f bar because after all i'm
assuming it means converged and now I'm
looking at a final result I'm trying to
get something like I sent a limit
theorem
you know if I'm if I'm only looking at
being very close to theta star that a
linearization is hopefully justified and
with some work what you end up with is
what I said before a stochastic
differential equation that looks like
that alright and so I'm gonna explain
this in in baby-talk in a moment so this
this is the it turns out this is too
hard to explain
I'll explain something in under stronger
conditions in a moment again a
stochastic differential equation for the
error now translate back to what you all
care about here's what you care about
under assumptions this this what I said
over here this square root of n times
the error converges in distribution to a
Gaussian where this covariance matrix
has a beautiful formula to lapin of
equation but notice that ok so how many
of you know about control and Lyapunov
functions
all right so it's that one half eye that
should bother you because you think that
you know I've gotta know de
this is the Eau de that the main OD of
interest like you know it's a motivation
of the algorithm it's the the the tool
analysis that I just used anyone control
is when they're starting to look at
sleet lit local stability to prove local
asymptotic stability you linearize you
take the a which is the derivative of f
bar at the theta star and that's the
thing of interest and so you're looking
at a I want a to be stable in order to
get convergence to the algorithm but
here in order for this to have a
solution
I need this matrix to have negative
eigenvalues so the real part of lambda a
has to be less than minus 1/2 to kill
off this ugly bit here and that's where
thing is that's what trouble comma comma
comes in so you can have a beautiful
stable Eau de everything's noise but if
that if you've got one eigenvalue which
is real place bigger than or equal to
minus 1/2 then everything can really
blow up in the sense of really slow
convergence so so in terms of question
questions for algorithm design how do
you fix an algorithm if this fails and
how can we optimize Sigma so I might be
able to come up with a new algorithm
that has the smallest possible
covariance and then of course
implications reinforcement learning
which is the focus next of a next
lecture so I'm going to answer these
questions at the end you know couldn't
finish up without and including some
examples
and you can imagine can anybody tell me
right off the bat what you do here if
all you want to do is get make sure you
could sell this way up in an equation so
you see the eigenvalues are all negative
I think they will be the eigen values of
a have negative real part you know but
maybe one of these is minus point zero
zero zero zero one as it is in
q-learning just crank up the game yeah
that's a thing so you could always just
crank up again and that's the solution
in terms of making the gate variance
finite and we'll see what happens with
that you know but that can be a really
good solution it could be terrible
depends yeah I'm going to and and I
thought I had a slick trick to get it
quickly and that's a mistake in the
slide see it's not that quick I've got
I'll show you all right so let's answer
that question so in the in the case of
uncorrelated noise and you just take a
linear problem okay let's just make
everything that forget linearization
just pretend that F was linear to just
to begin with and have a normalized
excursion like that
so I've linearized basically and the big
thing is that when this is uncorrelated
it all becomes really easy I don't have
to deal with this Markovian
plus non equation stuff uncorrelated
zero mean covariance called Sigma Delta
and here's where the damn 1/2 comes in
is that the square root of n plus 1 is
the square root of n times that if you
do a first or a Taylor series expansion
and this is just a long way of writing
the standard TOS whose expansion to
square root of n I'm writing it this way
because I'm going to multiply both sides
of this equation by square root of n
plus 1 and that's the form that's really
useful
all right because I'll get you know
square root of n plus 1 times this I'll
get a square root of n times that
because you see the 1 times square root
of N and that you'd think you could
ignore the 2 over 2 n inverse you know I
mean that's small but it's in the same
order the 1 over n it appears here
so that one over n term ends up getting
sucked into here
and you that's where you get the one
half hour than theta till then so you've
got the one over and outside the 1/2
square root of M is out thing what's
there there's a case why I hate using a
slides you know that's really use
chalkboard okay so basically I multiply
both sides of this you get this really I
should have a square of n plus 1 that I
can't ignore it doesn't matter because
there I've got a 1 over in here and it
doesn't matter where they put square
root of n plus 1 I squared of n all
right so that's the half okay and then I
can what I can do is I can just take you
know square both sides to take the
expectation and I get a a if I define
that to be the covariance at time n plus
1 I get this by doing what I've got a
sum of two terms that and that and what
I've done here is I've kept this thing
square that's this I've kept the cross
terms that's what the sum is here the
two cross terms but I've ignored this
whole thing squared because that's one
of her aunt's in that's over one over N
squared and it disappears okay it's just
it's it's something that's what you know
and there's a plus something Big O of 1
over N squared just I can ignore them
and and that's it so in the end
correlative case it's it's really easy
and and if you look at this it's
actually stochastic approximation
because is it x2 gets the approximation
with no noise you know I've got a my new
estimate is my old estimate plus again 1
over N times something that I'd like to
be zero is what it looks like and so you
can prove using the same stochastic
approximation or Elga arguments that as
long as the eigenvalues of a or they
satisfy the constraint sight I mentioned
this recursion will converge to the
solution of the Lyapunov equation that I
wrote down so you know basically what
you get is that if one eigenvalue
has real-part greater than equal to
minus 1/2 then typically the covariance
is infinity of course it depends on this
guy if this was zero that wouldn't be
true so this is full rank for example
that's true but then if all of them are
have real part less than minus 1/2 you
get this will converge very quickly to
the solution of the Lyapunov equation
there's quite a quite a simple argument
yeah it's nice
the fact that it's better it's more it's
really I mean a CLT is nice but it's
also nice their moments this is not this
is in addition to the CLT we actually
have the moments converge so is there
some other you know isn't is is it a
consequence of the little choice of
discretization is there some other way
you could discretize things that would
lead to it no because I mean it's so
perfect because in the end in the end
we're just getting that so that the disk
ization was just - just for analysis and
but at the end it all comes back to
reality you know
okay is there now the step size for the
one over and yeah we'll get to that yeah
so one of our n I'm the common filter
arguments tell you that if you want to
minimize covariance you're gonna have
some like 1 over N and you'll have a
sued matrix gain but they're
alternatives which are really cool and
I'll mention no in fact I'm just about
to mention your timing is perfect yeah
so so here's part of the answer so
suppose I stuck in a matrix here a
matrix sequence and I'd like to choose
it for good performance let's assume it
converges to something and linearize
like I did before just assume
everything's linear it is forget about
that and you see two things happen so
the G hits the a and so I could choose G
to make a nicer but the G hits the Delta
so there's a trade-off it looks like
this is a really complicated operation
problem because you know might be that I
have to make G huge to make a nice but
then I blow up the covariance but you
forget all that intuition you just say
yeah I can set this up as a common
filtering problem what's the best linear
filter of the observations you know to
get the minimum variance estimator
public law you can set it up as pure you
know clearly like a problem and what you
get is the optimal answer is minus a
universe and why because in its
Montecarlo you're just averaging you
know you're averaging your observations
and so that's what I've seen you it
looks like mother Carlo it sort of
resembles Newton Rapson and the first
person as far as we know that that
dreamed up these ideas was a famous guy
David Rupert in
and he called either the title of paper
is to guested in rap sunny he then it's
in the paper says maybe I should call it
gals stochastic Gauss Newton yeah I said
there's a lot of pondering in the paper
and it's optimal in the strongest
possible sense you know so if you take
this particular choice g star equals
minus a inverse if somebody else comes
up and they sink they claim to have a
better gain you tell them no my gain is
less than your is in the nutritional
sense so that's that's you know it's
super optimal so you know it's
incredible elementary this is i hope i
hope you agree consider how mysterious
it looks okay so that's what you'd be
shooting for really and and and we'll
talk about this again more like the next
time so so back to your question so
there's something I can explain and
Rupert has an another famous
contribution also polyak something
called Rupert poic averaging it's also
optimal in the sense of minimizing this
asymptotic covariance but these first
two bullets are missing and that's
really important so it turns out you can
have optimal asymptotic covariance and
really bad performance so also examples
of that so just to close out can still
actually get that half the a little 1530
left I'm gonna go through some examples
and just in one particular context
explain what I mean by people a Capuchin
okay so example let's just find the mean
of a of a random variable you know just
go back to yeah just go back to Monte
Carlo so the Delta again was you know
the random variable - it's me and I call
that ADA before and again we did this
normalization for analysis like I did
before here's what we have so if you
actually solve that lay up enough
function in the scalar case you'll get
the variance of Delta over two and you
get G squared over G minus 1/2 all right
and so if G is less than 1/2 you're dead
the variance is infinity and it G equals
1/2 it's infinity as well
and then there's a sweet spot G equals
one is optimal and then take a look at
this as G goes to infinity it's like G
squared over G so it's G so it's it's
just those of you know linearly with G
and if the variance here isn't too big
it's not such a big deal to overestimate
so over estimate the game isn't such a
big deal but underestimated it can kill
you
and underestimate is what most graduate
students would be excited about and show
you is the beautiful I when they came to
camp with a young graduate student maybe
not Berkeley graduate students not
Illinois graduate students graduates all
right so it's an example to stick
something boring let's take a Gaussian
random variable square it we know that
mean is 1 and the variance is to go I'm
told and so this this is 2 over 2 is 1
so just get them so let me show you what
happens in these contexts so it turns
out in this particular case you know
here's G equals 1 if just the estimates
hit 1 and stay there here's what Rupert
polyak averaging is does the same thing
oh I haven't defined it yet but I will
some reason G equals 1/2 looks pretty
well in this case don't be fooled it the
appearance is infinity it doesn't often
always work well but there is G equals
0.1 and here's where again a lot of
naive people would say look how smooth
it is
it's so cool like you know I've got such
a good good algorithm it's so stable and
it's just it'll take a billion years to
get near one and when you overestimate
the variance you give them the right air
really quickly but there's a lot of
noise around it says you know G equals
20 and 10 so your gain is 10 or 20 times
bigger than it should be so the CLT is
an awesome tool for a performance
evaluation damn it I mean this is just a
time horizon of a thousand and the CLT
for you know G equals one is perfect for
ethically and this is this weird polyak
averaging so we slowly unexplained so
here's this ingenious trick so if I if I
you know answer your question suppose
instead of one over N I take one of the
end of the grow where growers between a
half and one
it's like making that one over N but
putting a gain that blows up within
imagine putting an end to the one -
throw on top so you're making the gate
invariants super in four infinite by
create incredible volatility but then
you take the output of that and
establish it and no matrix gain it's
been proven have often lost until the
covariance and you see the CLT isn't
quite as quick to convert it to a big
deal but perfect that's perfect so you
can do this whenever you want this is a
way to improve variance this this this
trick and if you crease the game the CLT
is still beautiful indicator performance
so what we did here is we initialize the
algorithm with theta 0 uniformly
distributed between -5 and 5 and then we
had independent realizations at 10,000 I
don't know yeah and then got a histogram
and and there it is it's perfect you
just see if the variance is bigger you
know with 20 or or
now here's what happens when you have
infinite variants so again we initialize
theta zero uniformly between -5 and 5
and for this say gain equals 0.4 gain
equals point 1 wasn't worth looking at
it's too ridiculous but you see it's it
still sort of stays almost uniform but
over a wider and wider region and this
will this is 20 30 40 it is time goes
I'll get wide and wider because the
variance is infinity
the rate of convergence is not one of
the square root of n if the gain is 1/2
or less the gain is I can even compute
the rate of convergence but it won't be
one of the square root of n so this raid
your edge thing of 0.5 it kind of looks
Gaussian but as time goes on us can get
stretched out more and more because he
variances infinity
there's no CLT so yeah so it is only an
hour Jesus so this is just an
advertisement for next lecture if you
take a look at it's really I'm gonna go
through and give you a crash course in
stochastic control a pretty gentle one
and what we found is that if you look at
the standard algorithms are up there
so something called speedy queue
learning and if you apply poic with
averaging Dacula in which should in
principle make the variance and you know
optimal you get the the error after
million steps still being enormous but
if you apply something like
newton-raphson you can get convergence
like that and and you know just
incredible and and the point is that two
things are having to hear the entire
benefit of choosing the right gain is
variance because there's no dynamics
thank you learning you've got some
exotic dynamics and taming them with new
traps and is valuable as well so so so
this this this great convergence you get
is because it looks like Newton Rapson
so it so the transient behavior is good
and then also we're taking care of the
the variances
because we using the optimal Ultimatrix
game and the miracle is that it's stable
I mean it's amazing that Newton Rapson
can be stable for a problem it's not a
minimum problem
q-learning as I said it's some weird
choleric and relaxation there's no
structure there you'd think that would
help you with a matrix gain algorithm
like that something so next time we'll
apply this but there's a machinery
that's very special in reinforcement
learning that that saves the day so it's
a tea time I hope to do that
congratulate me so we found this on
whether you will function a derivation
of the function right but there it is
oh we get you up so for analysis
absolutely so yes that's right a is
equal to the you know the derivative of
f bar evaluated theta star that's right
well you know yeah yeah yeah being
that's right I mean it gives you the
meets a minimum covariant solution by by
choosing G equals minus a inverse we
ended up just averaging noise you know
you know that's all right so until and
Delta well in order to do this get this
covariance recursion I need to assume
that Delta was white but in the
Markovian case what it'll be is it'll be
the sum of a martingale difference and a
telescoping jerm a telescope in series
middle beat
this is important given you a question
for Markovian noise
yeah so for Marko noise you end up with
a martingale difference to them and
that's some of the telescopes when you
sum this it just becomes a difference at
the end points you know and that that
telescoping term you're able to put it
with a simple junk it disappears it's
but but the trouble is because of that
telescoping to your terms you can't do
this this cute recursive analysis you
have to look at this difference equation
approximation so you have to some of our
big adults to be able to ignore the
telescoping term this doesn't work in
Markovian case only all their ID but are
we being a price to reduce the variance
every time they're just no question yeah
I mean yeah I'm not I'm not promoting
this for dimensions of 1 million you
know but I will say I mean an examples
feel look at robotics at dimensions
aren't bigger than 20 or 30 or 40 I
wouldn't know why you wouldn't do this
and and after I'd also at least it's a
matrix times a vector and somebody here
knows the complexity of that what is it
it's squared yeah so at least we're not
really having to invert the entire
matrix it's just the N squared
complexity and so yeah so I don't know I
I'm very happy with dimensions twenty
thirty forty two hundred and then yes
then we then we have to do something
different but but the idea is that we've
got the pointless lectures we've got two
things we've got the chord deterministic
optimization dynamics and people devoted
decades and decades of their lives come
up with apart you know reduce complexity
turn reps and schemes
alright so slap those on but then I
remember there's as Ference issue as
well and you can take then try to make
the variants as small as possible
within this class of algorithms you're
looking at so I'm definitely not saying
we should always do exactly I mean
definitely don't think we should always
it's just it's the first thing to think
about and then we'll find from there
yeah sorry about your shifters oh not
that I can think of now you know that's
something I study a lot myself um I wish
it was I'd be fun
know nothing I know I could think oh
yeah possibly a sort of this exploration
exploitation trade up
oh yeah well we'll talk about that next
on Friday I mean here it's completely
orthogonal you know because this is just
a general analysis of these algorithms I
don't think the theory here helps us
with that question
I don't think because um we could make
your exploration would be better yeah
perhaps yeah it's nothing to think about
yeah I'll think it over
that's curious that's actually a fun
question by putting the right randomized
control laws reinforcement learning
could you actually make the asymptotic
variance better somehow because you'd be
at you're influencing Delta you know and
you give me typically think you'd be
making it bigger but if you clever with
exploration that you can make this
smaller you know that's true actually
and that's why and I have seen them I
mean that using month using randomized
rules can be crazy it can be much much
more efficient to use like quasi Monte
Carlo just have mixed use of sinusoids
and it's amazing how much faster
if anyone of you doing robotics don't
ever use the ran command in q-learning
just put in a mixture of sinusoid it's
like I have references if you want to
say and it's just like instantaneous how
fast the convergence is
okay teatime thank you
[Applause]